Queridos amigos, no es habitual decirlo, pero
si la Unión Europea siempre ha intentado
presentarse asimismo como poco menos que el
adalid de la limpieza y la transparencia,
lo cierto es que el último año no ha sido
precisamente bueno.
A tenor de todas las noticias que han ido
apareciendo sobre casos de corrupción en
el Parlamento Europeo, puede que muchos tengáis
la sensación de que el corazón político
del proyecto europeo está más infiltrado
por agentes extranjeros hasta el cuello.
Ah, ¿qué creéis que exagero?
Pues fijaos.
(29 enero 2024: Correspondencia filtrada arroja
luz sobre los vínculos entre eurodiputada
letona y el FSB - ERR)
(15 diciembre 2022: Un caso de soborno abre
grietas en el Parlamento Europeo y encuentra
dinero oculto
Los fiscales dicen que el glamuroso estilo
de vida de una parlamentaria europea escondía
un escándalo de corrupción qatarí.
- The New York Times)
(14 diciembre 2022: Escándalo de corrupción
de Qatar: Marruecos también implicado en
un presunto pago a Panzeri)
Rusia, Qatar, Marruecos, incluso Mauritania…
lo que hasta ahora se hacía ver como un espacio
puro, transparente y limpio, acumula en los
últimos meses más escándalos que las infidelidades
de Tiger Woods.
Todo empezó a finales de 2022 cuando se destapó
un macro-caso de corrupción por el que varios
europarlamentarios recibieron sobornos de
Qatar y de otros países como Marruecos y
Mauritania.
Queridos amigos, amigas, lo que os vamos a
contar en este vídeo son ni más ni menos
que algunas de las mayores vergüenzas de
la política europea.
Aunque quizás lo más sorprendente es el
papel que un país como Marruecos ha jugado
en toda esta historia.
¿Preparados?
Pues… gasolina y ¡Arranquemos!
Para ponernos en situación vamos a empezar
contando qué es exactamente el Qatargate,
o el Moroccogate,la escisión marroquí de
este mismo escándalo.
Hablamos del mayor caso de corrupción de
la historia de la Unión Europea.
Un caso que antes de explotar en diciembre
de 2022 estuvo bastante tiempo bajo investigación.
Con pinchazos telefónicos incluidos.
Al final, todo saltó por los aires cuando
la policía belga descubrió al padre de Eva
Kaili, una eurodiputada socialdemócrata griega
y vicepresidenta del Europarlamento, saliendo
de un hotel con una maleta.
En esa maleta llevaba la friolera de, agarraos
a la silla, 750.000 euros en efectivo, casi
un millón de dólares.
Al mismo tiempo la policía también detuvo
a Antonio Panzeri PRON: Pant-seri], un ex-eurodiputado
socialdemócrata italiano, que después se
ha sabido es ni más ni menos que el capo
de la trama.
Pero no solo eso.
Entre un viernes y un lunes las autoridades
belgas encontraron un millón y medio de euros
en efectivo en varias casas y oficinas de
los investigados.
[Vamos que se habían mon tado un negocio
por todo lo grande.]
Además Panzeri también canalizaba dinero
de Qatar y Marruecos a través de una ONG
con sede en Bruselas, una ONG que él mismo
fundó en 2019, Fight Impunity, que se supone
que luchaba contra las violaciones de los
derechos humanos.
[Con dinero de Qatar y Marruecos, eso sí.
Curioso, ¿No os parece?.]
Pero aún más, esa ONG la llevaba junto a
su asistente Francesco Giorgi, que es el novio
de Eva Kaili.
Vamos que al final todo quedaba en familia.
EL caso es que el objetivo de todo este entramado
corrupto era que esos eurodiputados constituyeran
lobbies para influir en el Parlamento Europeo
sobre ciertos temas sensibles, siguiendo siempre
los intereses de Qatar, Marruecos y Mauritania.
(Hablamos de una trama sin precedentes en
la historia de la Unión Europea.
Una red de engaños, sobornos, maletines llenos
de dinero en efectivo y lobbies ilegales impulsados
por eurodiputados en ejercicio y también
antiguos miembros de la cámara.
Una red corrupta cuyos miembros se compraban
inmuebles en cash, que manipulaban dosieres
sobre violaciones de derechos humanos en ciertos
países, que vetaban el reconocimiento de
activistas contra la esclavitud o que ocultaban
acciones de servicios de espionaje extranjeros.)
Puede que muchos de vosotros ya hayáis oído
hablar de todo esto del Qatargate, pero casi
seguro que la última vez que lo hicisteis
fue hace ya bastante tiempo y, además, sin
mucho detalle, ¿no es así?
Es posible que incluso creáis que el tema
ya está completamente cerrado y solucionado.
Sin embargo, nada más lejos de la realidad.
Las investigaciones continúan y se siguen
publicando detalles, los últimos hace apenas
dos meses, cuando se filtraron cientos de
documentos del caso cuyo alcance es mucho
mayor del que se pensaba.
De hecho, aquí es donde ya empiezan a aparecer
cosas un tanto raras.
Y es que ahora, poco más de un año después
de que explotara todo este escándalo, no
hay ni un solo acusado en la cárcel.
Y lo que es aún peor, el fiscal federal a
cargo del caso, Raphael Malagnini, dimitió
de su cargo en octubre de 2023.
De repente encontró un trabajo mejor.
Y algo parecido ocurrió también con Michel
Claise, el primer juez belga que se encargó
de este asunto.
Tuvo que dimitir tras descubrirse que su hijo,
su propio hijo tenía una empresa con el hijo
de otra eurodiputada también involucrada
en este macro-caso de corrupción.
Y aún más, en el marco de las investigaciones,
había solicitudes de arresto e interrogatorio
para un ministro qatarí y un diplomático
marroquí que, de la noche a la mañana, desaparecieron.
Algunas con motivos bastante sorprendentes.
18 noviembre 2023: El juez belga que hasta
hace poco dirigía la investigación de corrupción
Qatargate retiró una orden de arresto internacional
contra un alto funcionario qatarí a cambio
de la ayuda de Doha para lograr la liberación
de un trabajador humanitario belga detenido
por Irán - The Bruselas Times)
¿Hacemos trueque?
Impunidad a cambio de una mediación.
No parece un mal negocio.
Hasta Pedro Sánchez estaría orgulloso.
Pero es que aquí no acaba todo…
También hay políticos que, a pesar de las
fuertes pruebas sobre su implicación, ni
siquiera han sido investigados.
(Por ejemplo, la eurodiputada socialdemócrata
belga María Arena, reconoció haber aceptado
viajes y haberse hospedado en Qatar y en Marruecos,
a todo trapo y a gastos pagados por estos
países.
Y no solo eso, en casa de su hijo encontraron
casi 300.000 euros en efectivo de origen desconocido.
Pero sin embargo está, libree y sin cargos.
Para más inri, Panzeri y Arena dirigieron
la subcomisión de derechos humanos del Parlamento
Europeo.
Sí sí, de derechos humanos…
Y tanto Kaili como Arena siguen siendo a día
de hoy eurodiputadas.)
Y claro, con todo esto puede que muchos os
estéis preguntando…
Pero, ¿cómo demonios puede estar ocurriendo
todo esto en el corazón mismo de la Unión
Europea y que además haya pasado sin pena
ni gloria?
Y es que, a ver, los eurodiputados cobran
salarios de más de 10.000 euros mensuales
precisamente para que no se corrompan.
Esa al menos es la justificación que se da.
Y aunque la avaricia de algunos es algo inevitable,
la tibia respuesta del europarlamento pues,
¿qué queréis qué os diga?
Da que pensar.
¿Y si en la Unión Europea hay más infiltraciones
y presiones extranjeras de las que pensábamos?
¿Cómo un país tan pobre e irrelevante en
la escena internacional como es Marruecos
pudo crear una enorme trama de corrupción
en Bruselas?
Pues bien, en este vídeo os vamos a hablar
sobre todo de este segundo caso, el de Marruecos.
¿Qué buscaba Rabat en el Parlamento Europeo?
Y la pregunta más importante: ¿qué le debe
la Unión Europea a Marruecos?
Pues bien, veámoslo.
T1(‘MOROCCOGATE’: LA MANO DE RABAT)
El escándalo Qatargate tiene, como os hemos
dicho, una ramificación marroquí.
Esta ramificación, a la que se le llama Moroccogate,
no ha ocupado tantas portadas en los medios
de comunicación europeos, pero es todavía
más sorprendente que la injerencia de Qatar
en la política europea.
Ahora bien, ¿cómo se había infiltrado Marruecos
en la política europea?
Pues veréis, esta historia tiene dos rostros
principales: el ex-eurodiputado Antonio Panzeri
y el que todavía es embajador de Marruecos
en Polonia, Abderrahim Atmoun, que servía
como contacto de Rabat con los políticos
europeos corruptos.
(Aunque tanto Qatar como Marruecos niegan
tajantemente su participación en ninguna
trama para corromper la política europea,
lo cierto es que los investigadores belgas
tienen pruebas de sobra para refutar esa defensa.
En concreto, Bélgica cree que Atmoun jugó
un papel clave a la hora de canalizar el dinero
con el que se pagaba a los eurodiputados corruptos.
Incluso la mujer y la hija de Panzeri se beneficiaban
de los fondos marroquíes a través de una
tarjeta de crédito.)
El caso es que Atmoun y Panzeri copresidían
la Comisión Parlamentaria Mixta UE-Marruecos,
que es el principal enlace de contacto entre
el Parlamento Europeo y Marruecos.
Básicamente, bajo la dirección de Panzeri
y Atmoun, esa comisión trabajaría no para
defender los intereses de Europa respecto
a Marruecos, sino al revés.
De hecho, en unos documentos marroquíes filtrados
por un hacker, entre los años 2014 y 2015,
Rabat calificaba a Panzeri de gran aliado
e íntimo amigo, llegando a decir que era
capaz de contrarrestar el creciente activismo
de sus oponentes en el Europarlamento.
Ahora bien, exáctamente, ¿qué necesitaba
Marruecos de la Unión Europea?
¿Qué podían ofrecer los eurodiputados corruptos
a Rabat?
Pues bien, os lo contamos ahora mismo.
Atentos.
T2(CORRUPCIÓN, PRESIÓN, CHANTAJES)
La relación entre Marruecos y la Unión Europea,
especialmente con los países del sur como
España, Italia y Portugal, se podría definir
como de mutuo interés.
Por un lado, la Unión Europea necesita a
Marruecos para contener uno de los mayores
problemas que lleva años enfrentando Europa:
la inmigracióin ilegal.
Un problema que ha puesto en jaque varias
veces a España, Italia y Grecia y que, en
el caso especialmente de España, Marruecos
utiliza frecuentemente como chantaje.
Por ejemplo, con cosas como esta.
N5(19 May 2021: Spain and Morocco in diplomatic
crisis after 8,000 migrants enter Spanish
territory - CNBC)
(19 mayo 2021: España y Marruecos en crisis
diplomática después de que 8.000 inmigrantes
entrasen en territorio español - CNBC)
En aquella ocasión incluso se vio cómo las
fuerzas de seguridad marroquíes no hacían
absolutamente nada para evitar que miles de
personas asaltasen la frontera con España
en Ceuta.
Y este es tan solo un ejemplo del poder que
tiene Marruecos para desestabilizar y chantajear
a países europeos.
Pero la inmigración no es la única vía
que utilizan.
En concreto, en el caso Moroccogate y según
los investigadores belgas, se mencionaba en
documentos expresamente la cuestión de los
derechos de pesca y del Sáhara Occidental.
Ahora bien, ¿qué es exactamente eso de los
derechos de pesca?
Pues veréis, la Unión Europea tiene la competencia
exclusiva en el ámbito de la política comercial
común, y en eso se incluyen también la firma
de acuerdos pesqueros para que los buques
europeos puedan faenar en caladeros extranjeros.
Y claro, la cuestión, un trato favorable
con Marruecos en torno a los derechos de pesca
conllevaba ciertas contrapartidas.
Concretamente, según los servicios secretos
belgas, los eurodiputados implicados acordaron
desviar las críticas a Marruecos en materia
de derechos humanos y el estatus del Sáhara
Occidental, que Marruecos se ha empeñado
en cambiar de una vez para siempre.
(En 2016 el rey marroquí, Mohammed VI, declaró
que el asunto del Sáhara Occidental sería
a partir de entonces la mayor prioridad del
reino alauí en materia de política exterior.
Ese discurso vino acompañado de un cambio
radical en la forma de hacer diplomacia por
parte de Rabat.
Según el periodista marroquí Aboubakr Jamaï,
ahora exiliado, los diplomáticos marroquíes
desde entonces actúan con una arrogancia
y unas formas sin precedentes, y se empezaron
a permitir cosas que antes estaban prohibidas.
Muy probablemente se refería precisamente
a cosas como la corrupción por parte de figuras
como Atmoun a miembros del Parlamento Europeo.)
Si bien el Moroccogate no representaba una
cantidad mayoritaria de dinero dentro del
Qatargate, Marruecos sí era el país más
agresivo en sus formas.
En 2019, por ejemplo, Atmoun negoció un acuerdo
financiero entre Panzeri y el servicio de
espionaje marroquí, que es conocido como
la Dirección General de Estudios y Documentación.
Panzeri confesó que él y su asistente Giorgi
acordaron recibir un mínimo de 50.000 euros
anuales cada uno a cambio de ganar voluntades
a favor de los intereses de Marruecos dentro
y fuera del Europarlamento.
Pero es que es más, entre 2019 y 2022 Atmoun,
Panzeri y el jefe de la inteligencia marroquí,
Mohamed Yassine Mansouri, participaron en
al menos tres reuniones
(“Atmoun, al ser una persona extrovertida,
quería conocer al mayor número de personas
posible.
[...] Y por supuesto, a aquellos que podrían
ser útiles para la causa marroquí”.
- Antonio Panzeri, a los investigadores)
Pero ahí no acaba todo.
Panzeri también ayudó a Atmoun a ganarse
la simpatía de otros miembros del parlamento
europeo con responsabilidades sobre expedientes
en los que Rabat estaba interesado.
Por ejemplo, el diputado italiano socialdemócrata,
Andrea Cozzolino, se metió de lleno en el
Moroccogate por formar parte del comité que
investigaba el uso por parte precisamente
de Marruecos, del software espía Pegasus.
Ahora bien, puede que os estéis preguntando
exáctamente qué cosas concretas logró Marruecos
al influir dentro de la política europea,
¿no?
(Pues a parte de lo que ya os hemos contado,
Rabat consiguió votos en contra de conceder
el premio Sájarov de derechos humanos del
Parlamento Europeo a dos activistas que eran
opositores a Marruecos y Mauritania.
También lograron aprobar una resolución
contra Argelia y garantizar que las menciones
a Marruecos desaparecieran de un informe del
Europarlamento sobre violaciones de derechos
humanos.)
¿Sorprendidos?
Marruecos jugaba a sus anchas en los pasillos
de Bruselas.
Ahora bien, puede que muchos llegados a este
punto os estéis preguntando…
¿qué diantres hizo el Parlamento Europeo
después de descubrirse todo este pastel?
Pues bie n, la versión oficial es que están
colaborando estrechamente con las autoridades
belgas en la investigación.
Pero la realidad es que los movimientos del
parlamento desde que saltó este caso en diciembre
de 2022 han estado más encaminados a tapar
agujeros y restaurar su imagen que realmente
a descubrir hasta dónde llega la trama.
Porque investigaciones internas serias, lo
que se dice serias, digamos que ha habido
entre pocas o ninguna.
Eso sí, en enero de 2023, poco más de un
mes después del arresto de Panzeri y el resto
de sospechosos, el Parlamento Europeo aprobó
por primera vez en 25 años una condena al
historial de violación de derechos humanos
de Marruecos.
Obviamente esto enfadó mucho a Marruecos
y la respuesta no tardó en llegar.
N6(El fin del acuerdo pesquero alienta los
contactos entre Marruecos y la UE pero el
Polisario alerta: “Es mantener la piratería”
Este lunes ha expirado el protocolo de pesca
UE-Marruecos a la espera del pronunciamiento
de la justicia europea sobre un acuerdo declarado
ilegal por la explotación de los recursos
marinos del Sáhara Occidental sin consentimiento
del Polisario.
- El Independiente)
La disputa diplomática actual está haciendo
que la estabilidad en algunos asuntos que
antes estaba más o menos garantizada, ahora
esté pendiente de un hilo.
Y es que, aparte del acuerdo pesquero, Rabat
es también un importantísimo socio para
Europa en lo que se refiere a la lucha contra
el terorrismo islamista.
Aquí los intercambios de inteligencia resultan
claves.
Y tampoco se puede olvidar que más de 2 millones
de marroquíes viven en Europa, y entre 2
y 3 millones más de descendientes de marroquíes
que lógicamente se sienten todavía muy identificados
con ese país.
De hecho, se sabe que hoy por hoy la inteligencia
de Rabat está activamente infiltrándose
en las comunidades marroquíes de varios países
europeos para tratar de influenciar a los
jóvenes cultural y políticamente, aparte,
por supuesto, de controlar a los disidentes.
Evidentemente las garras de Marruecos en Europa
son grandes, y el Moroccogate es quizás el
último y mayor escándalo de muchos otros
casos de injerencias marroquíes en la política
europea a distinta escala.
Por ejemplo en España conocernos casos de
sobra.
Casos como estos.
N8(15 junio 2023: La Eurocámara exige a España
investigar espionaje de Marruecos al Gobierno,
incluyendo a Sánchez - Europapress)
N9(4 agosto 2023: El español Sánchez en
un viaje 'secreto' de vacaciones a Marruecos
que enfada a la oposición por el conflicto
del Sahara
Ha habido un cambio de última hora en el
destino de vacaciones de Pedro Sánchez que
nadie conocía.
- Euronews)
Y a todo esto le tenemos que sumar que frecuentemente
criminales de todo tipo: de guante blancos,
narcos o, incluso, terroristas, se refugian
en Marruecos precisamente para intentar escapar
de las autoridades europeas.
La cuestión, la duda que ahora muchos tenemos
es…
¿Qué ocurrirá con las relaciones entre
Europa y Marruecos tras la caída de su red
de contactos corruptos?
Pues bien, estaremos muy atentos a todo esto
aquí, en VisualPolitik, pero ahora las preguntas
son para vosotros:
¿Qué pensáis que debería hacer la Unión
Europea para evitar que se vuelvan a repetir
escándalos de corrupción e infiltración
como el Moroccogate?
¿Debería la UE ser más dura con Marruecos
haciendo valer su posición de superioridad
económica y militar?
¿Tiene solución el chantaje constante que
rodea todas las relaciones entre los gobiernos
europeos y el marroquí?
Como siempre déjanos tu comentario aquí
abajo.
y si te ha resultado interesante este vídeo
no olvides darle a like y suscribirte a nuestro
canal para no perderte ninguna novedad.
Una vez más, muchas gracias por estar ahí.
¡Un saludo y hasta la próxima!